[Music]
title fight
[Music]
[Music]
you just always hear like nice
compliment
all right so I guess we will continue
now before we start with the next talk I
would like to ask if there's anyone that
would like to present an open problem in
the open problem session after the talk
because so far we have none
I can I can volunteer to get beers over
from all right maybe just think about it
in the course of the talk and if you
ever know if the problem we can start
the session of how does it talk so the
next talk will be by Omega and to talk
about many favorites I'll talk about
lifting non-negative rang this kind of
is very connected to the talk that you
saw before but Nika and this is based on
joint work with Provost Qatari and pasar
la govinda i'll start by stating the
main theorem informally and then we'll
state the crux of the theorem more
formally so the main theorem is that for
many CSP CSP is that we all care about
if you want to beat the trivial
algorithm the trivial algorithm where
you just don't even look at the instance
make a random guess and check how well
it does to beat this trivial algorithm
by an LP you need sub exponential size
of peas so for example for 3sat for max
3sat there's a trivial 7/8 approximation
algorithm just take a random assignment
it satisfies 7/8 fraction of the
assignments and of the constraints if
you want to get slightly better seven or
eight plus point zero one then you need
an linear program whose size is
exponential or exponential in n to some
constant and the same holds for max cut
and there's a trivial algorithm for max
cut which is take a random cut and that
cuts half the edges if you want to do
point five one then you need a sub
exponential size LP and the previous
best result in this line was due to
channle raghavan destroyer who showed
that to be the trivial algorithm you
needed quasi-polynomial size
peace and what we do here is to get it
all the way up to sub-exponential and
it's more than this I mean the way I
presented it it sounds like a negative
result in that we're saying that Elpis
cannot solve some problems but it's the
main result is an upper bound or and an
algorithm it says that for CSP is as for
a CSP s are concerned sub-exponential
sighs LPS are as powerful as a special
kind of LP okay as R as powerful as
sherilee atoms relaxations of roughly
the same size so if you start this size
to do the S you end up with something
which is like s rounds or polyester on
social items and once we have this using
known results non lower bounds for
sherilee items you get the results that
are stated before so I'm not going to
talk about either of these two theorems
today I just stated them because those
are the main motivation for the work in
the first place but how do we talk about
LPS for CSP s so I said these are lower
bounds on the size of linear programs I
want to characterize how you can solve
the CSP by arbitrary linear programs and
there's a way to formalize this using
the language of external formulations we
see many talks in this workshop on it
but they were all for polytopes but now
we're talking about approximation
problem so you need to extend those
definitions a little bit but at the end
of the day all of these definitions
reduce by this very nice result of
gonococcus can further expand it on my
channle Dragon destroyer to computing
the non- rank of certain matrices okay
so that's going to be our starting point
you can get all of this size lower
bounds for CSP s and the simulation
results if you can understand the non-
rank of certain matrices all right I'll
tell you what this matrices are by
giving an example and then we'll talk
about what sorts of things we'd like to
know let's look at an example which is
maxcut so let's say I want a C comma s
approximation from maxsa this is
something that we saw and mothers talk
for instance so here I want my
found to output a value which is at most
C if I tell you that the optimal cut is
at most s SS like soundness II is like
correctness and so on
and was it best size LP for this for
this problem the best you can do is can
be characterized by the following matrix
which I'll call em cut so the matrix the
rows are indexed by graphs who's the
best cut values at most s the columns
are index back cuts which are s and G
comma s at entries basically C minus cut
G of s and just from the definition you
can see that this is always non-negative
and following the work of Jana kaki CLRS
CLRS showed that the best size LP
achieving the best the least has LP to
solve this problem for max cut is
equivalent to the non-negative rank of
this matrix so we started out from
looking for all possible LPS which can
do some things and we ended up with very
concrete question which is to understand
the non-negative rank of this matrix so
how do we approach the non-negative rank
of this matrix first of all let's just
we saw this definition already in
Micah's talk but let me introduce the
definition again so let's say I have a
non-negative matrix M then the
non-negative rank of matrix is the min
over all R such that I can write M as
the sum of rank one matrices of our rank
one matrices where each matrix the
factors are non-negative the usual
notion of rank except that you also
impose a non-negative constraints on the
vectors that are involved in the
factorization and this is very well
connected I mean this is sort of the the
core tool that's used in studying
external formulations and proving lower
boss or non-negative rank is not easy in
fact the first exponential separation
was only proved maybe about five six
years ago jitter fiorini and others so
what this work does is actually give a
technique or lower bonding the non- rank
of a family of matrices of a class of
matrices and what is this class of
matrices there's a pattern matrices okay
here's the outline of the talk well
first talk about pattern matrices and
how we can bound the non- rank of
pattern matrices and we'll see how to do
this using certain tools from
communication complexity so if you want
to take one thing away from in this talk
I'd like it to be this second part which
I think is the more conceptual part of
this work and then if there's time we'll
briefly sketch the decomposition theorem
okay let's start with non-negative rank
of pattern matrices so pattern matrices
are special kinds of matrices which you
build out of functions so I start with a
function on the hypercube which takes n
bits and outputs a real number and from
this I'm going to build a matrix and
paramedics are the things that Mika
called lifted functions so the matrix
the columns are going to be indexed by X
and the rows are going to be indexed by
Y think of X being Alice's input and Y
as being Bob or column players input and
the inputs come from the inputs are n
symbols they're the symbols over some
alphabet Sigma we now combine these
inputs to get an input for our function
f so we need a gadget G which takes two
symbols and outputs a boolean value zero
one value and we now define a function M
f of X comma Y where the first input to
our function f is obtained by applying
the gadget to the first two symbols of
ulsan Bob and the second input is going
to be the output of the gadget G the
function G on this second symbols of
Alice and Bob and so on and so forth
so we call this function f the outer
function this function G is called the
gadget okay you should think of the
gadget as being something small the
outer function is something being more
complicated okay and this gives me my
function MF which is f composed with G
to the N pictorially we have the matrix
which looks like this we said the rows
are indexed by symbols of length n over
the alphabet Sigma column similarly and
the ex-wife entry is the output of F of
G to the N of X comma okay so these are
called pattern matrices because in some
sense the pattern of F is embedded in
this matrix in many many places you'll
see a copy of F in every row every
column and many other places and what
we'd like to the main meta question when
you look at this matrices is to
understand various measures of this
matrices of the of the matrix lifted
matrix M F in terms of some property of
F okay so if I want some notion of rank
of I want to characterize some notion of
rank of the matrix M F in terms of some
corresponding measure of the outer
function little F for example it's
fairly easy to see that the usual notion
of rank if I look at the rank of this
matrix M F it's exactly characterized by
the degree as a polynomial of my outer
function yes but for this work and for
the application that we're interested in
me to understand the non-negative rank
of this lifted matrix M F of the pattern
matrix M F so here's the set up again we
have our outer function f which takes
non-negative values we have our gadget G
which combines two symbols and produces
a bit and from that we can define our
lifted function lifted matrix and I'd
like to know whether I would like to
characterize the non-negative rank in
terms of some measure of F so what
measure of F should you use it's it's a
pretty natural measure given the context
if you play with it then you'll end up
with this measure
so what's the measure is it's a non
negative analog of degree
well almost but there's some subtlety
here so it's called degree plus the
degree plus of F is the least number D
such that I can write f as the sum of
non negative hunters okay I'm going to
write f which is a non-negative function
as a sum of non-negative functions but I
want each of these small functions
involved in the summation the only
depend on D variables
so each of this H is only depends on D
variables the least if I wish we can do
that is degree plus and it's easy to see
that you get an upper bound on the
non-negative rank in terms of degree
plus okay so the non-negative rank of
the lifted matrix is at most
exponential in something which depends
on alphabet size that's not too
important times the degree plus of F
essentially you can just expand each of
these H eyes to get a corresponding nice
rank one term so given this upper bound
the main question we'd like to address
is whether there's a corresponding lower
bound is this bound tight or is it not
so we're going to show that it is
basically tight but for a specific
choice of the gadget and alphabet so the
gadget we'll look at today is the one
that meek also mentioned which is the
inner product gadget so think of the
alphabet as being strings of length B
where B is going to be some parameter
and the output of the gadget is the
inner product mod two of these to be bit
strings it also worked with more general
gadgets but inner product is the most
natural one for which this analysis
works
it's a real main theorem from which the
results I mentioned on the first slide
follow is that as long as B is at least
some constant times log n I'm ignoring
constant factors and I'm going to
normalize so that the expectation of my
function is s this is just normalization
term then the non-negative rank of my
lifted matrix is at least exponential in
B which is log of the alphabet size
times degree plus of F with an small
additive shift okay so if you compare
this to the upper bound I mentioned on
the previous slide this is tight except
for the omega1 in the exponent and this
additive shift of 100 over n this
additive shift doesn't matter for
application so it's fine for things that
we do in questions
it's an exponent again
it's in the experts an exponent
explanation betimes degree plus of f so
the lower bound is basically B times
degree plus of F in exponent except is f
plus 1 or M no this is for the inner
product this for the inner product the
lower bound is for inner product the
upper bound for every G ok and I mean if
you'd make your G trivial then your
lower bound will break so once you have
this I should say something right so
what was known I mean this lifting
theorems for non-native rank were also
looked at before something that Mike
also mentioned there is some work in
there is a lifting theorem which works
up to some range in CLRS and in this
work with me Katyusha Harlow where
Thomas Watson and david zuckerman we
showed a lifting tr4 approximate
non-negative rank the similar
characterization similar lower bound on
the approximant non-negative rank of
matrix in terms of the approximate
degree of the function you start with
something weaker and also end up with
something's like liquor
so the approximation is very controlled
like you're just adding there you're
just adding yeah so once we have this
lifting theorem you can just plug this
into the abstraction in CLRS to get the
CSP results that I mentioned and one
reason is that if you think of this MCAT
matrix I mentioned before I wrote down
this pattern matrices can be found as
sub matrices of this cut matrix as I
said so that's how you get the lower
bound so f will be like as in previous
work just like a hard instance F is
going to be just some counting problem
like a hard instance for our items and
another thing to keep in mind is that to
get the CSP results for example you
cannot use just a lifting result for
approximate non-negative rank the
matrices that show up when you're trying
to show lower bounds for CSPs they have
small approximate non-negative rank but
big non-negative rank so any technique
which kind of trying to lower bound only
the approximate non-negative rank is not
going to work you can just you can get
like an N log is collect log n times log
1 or epsilon is by sampling if you are a
lot of exactly if it's additive epsilon
you can just get can get by with log 1
or epsilon bits of communication
so here's the outline again I stated the
main result which is a lifting theorem
for pattern matrices which gives a lower
bound on the non-negative rank of
pattern matrices and now let me tell you
how the main was the crux of the proof
so the character the proof is something
that comes out of communication
complexity right which we call
decomposing high mean entropy product
distribution so let's get there a little
slowly so let's see color setup we have
this outer function fer gadget G we have
a lifted matrix and we'd like to show a
lower bound on the non-negative rank of
the lifted matrix okay let's work by
contradiction so every lower bound is
real an upper bound in that sense what
we'll say is that if the non-negative
rank of this matrix is small then we'll
show that function f has small degree
plus
okay so starting from this assumption we
would like to show or say that degree
plus of F is small and that will give us
a contradiction that we want so how can
we find a small degree plist certificate
for F let's see what the non- ranked
assumption means so just from definition
f MF having small non-negative rank
means that I can write it as sum of rank
one matrices where the factors are
non-negative and since these are
non-negative I'm going to normalize them
so that these factors are actually
correspond to distributions on the rows
and columns by just changing the scaling
term can make sure that I can write MF
as lambda I which is kind of the scaling
term times UI which is now a
distribution on the rows times we are
transpose which is now a distribution on
the columns
and our equality are the definition of
the lifted matrix says that F of G - n
of X comma y equals this for all X comma
1 and as I said they call them pattern
matrices because you can find many
copies of F embedded in this matrix
right and we're going to exploit that in
a strong way but also sort of in a weak
way when you think about it analytically
since this equality holds for all X
comma y it will hold when an average or
some sets of X comma Y okay but I'm
going to average or a specific set of X
comma 1 so let's fix this n bit strings
Z which is just a boolean and bit string
and I'm going to sample X comma Y whose
image under the gadget Z to the N is
actually Z so look at all pairs of rows
and columns whose output under the
gadget is Z and let's look at F of Z
since the output of the gadget on every
of this every one of these points is
exactly Z the expectation the expected
entry of the matrix under this
distribution is also f of Z
and by as by linearity of expectation
and using the factorization
representation I had before I can move
the expectation inside okay although
this is very straightforward but we'll
end up with something looking very nice
in a minute and so we are looking at
summation lambda I expectation of UI of
X and we have Y where X comma Y are
being sample from this Joint
Distribution okay and there's a simple
way to kind of switch variables and make
this distribution independent okay
instead of sampling from X comma Y so
that the gadget output is Z I can sample
X comma Y independently and look at the
expectation of GTN of X comma equaling Z
so by changing another scaling term here
everything boils down to looking at
expectation of sampling X under the
distribution UI and sampling Y
independently from a distribution VI and
looking at the probability that the
output of the gadget equals the string Z
okay so we have this quantity here and
what can we say about these functions
that's the main question we'd like to
understand now because let's say we were
very lucky and we maybe just had like a
few of these components then can we say
something nice about these functions on
the hypercube that we get so for example
it would be very nice and we can all go
home if these functions were all just
sum of non-negative hunters yeah
yeah oh now you're thinking in this
measures you I envy as for distributions
yeah okay so basically doing this
experiment where a sample X
independently and X according to you I
and y independently going to VI and then
checking whether or not the output of
the gadget equals my input string Z okay
and if these functions are simple then
I'm done for example this is a D Hunter
then I get a nice representation
everything is there
we are done we had a small degree plus
representation okay so let's abstract
this out even further and let's look at
the following quantity I have two
distributions on Sigma to the N on the
rows and columns a sample a row index
independently according to one of them
and a column index according
independently according to the other one
and I look at the probability that the
output of the gadget equals my input
string Z let's call let me call that a
UV Z for acceptance probability of Z
under the distribution you come a week
okay so can we identify any structure in
a UV if these functions are simple if
they were small degree hunters for
example then we would be done
unfortunately that's not true that
cannot be true all the time because I
mean without any restriction you and we
could just pick out one particular point
in the matrix right it could just be a
delta function and here's where the
small non negative rank shows up the
thumb rule to keep in mind here is that
small naked non negative rank
corresponds to the factors being high
mean entropy distributions
and here Biman entropy we say
distribution has been entropy at least K
if every event under the distribution
has probability at most two to the minus
K of a current okay so no event is more
likely than two to the minus K so if you
have small number of factors then you
can sort of prove prune out some factors
to are ensure that all the remaining
ones have high mean entropy and all this
has the same question again
so we have our alphabet Sigma which is
0-1 to the B we have a gadget which was
the inner product let's look at the
alphabets as being slightly bigger than
log N and now we have two distributions
you come up we both of them have very
high mean entropy how high they're
basically missing entropy corresponding
to T blocks or P symbols so entropy is
at least n minus K times B what can we
say about aue well let's look at some
examples
the simplest example I can think of I
mean entropy distributions are uniform
ones right so you and we are just
uniform and Sigma to the N what is a UV
in this case because G is a balanced
function so it's just going to be
uniform as well so G to the N of X being
uniform and by being uniform is uniform
distribution so the probability that it
equals something is actually a constant
exactly going to be 1 over 2 to the N
that's it
what other sort of the next complicated
case I can think of for distributions
which miss steep symbols of entropy is
to force it to misty symbols of entropy
so let's say I fix the first day symbols
of you first these symbols of V and
everything else is uniform so the blue
parts are fixed strings
everything else is uniform then if you
look at the output of the gadget what
you'll get is the first key symbols are
fixed and the rest are uniformly so in
this case acceptance function is
actually a t hunter it's a t
non-negative hunter in fact this looks
good but there's one more slightly bad
case which is I still have T fixed
coordinates but the others are not
perfectly uniform right the first they
are fixed in both U and V and in the
remaining in you the distribution is
product on the coordinates but each
coordinate just has very high minute
repeat it's not uniform but has have
been entropy let's say almost the full
beer 0.9 be ok what can you tell me
about the acceptance function then well
it turns out that even in this case the
first D coordinates are fixed so those
things are lost anyway the remaining
ones you still get uniform distribution
so the output is again a t hunter and
here's where we use property of the
inner product gadget that it's a to
source extractor meaning if I give it to
two symbols with very high entropy then
the output is almost close to being
uniform
and this our main structural result is
that these three cases ashen shall
essentially cover all possible cases
okay
so concretely to formalize this we need
the notion of block-wise density which
was introduced in work that I mentioned
before so let's have a distribution X
with a sample from you which has n
symbols will say this block wise dense
if the following holds now look at any
subset of coordinates the mean entropy
there is nearly the maximum possible so
the mean entropy rate there is a
constant and particular diminutive of X
restricted I is at least 0.9 times the
maximum possible which is B times I so
whenever this is satisfied we call X
block wise dance then there is
conjunctive block questions which kind
of generalizes the second case that I
have mentioned before which is basically
block wise dance with few fixed
coordinates thrown in okay so here I
have D coordinates which are fixed the
rest are all block questions and then
there is aligned block wise dance so
here I have to block I have two
distributions which are block questions
and some fixed coordinates but I also
want the fixed coordinates to align so
have you come a V they have some D
coordinates which are fixed in both of
them and in everything else they are
almost uniform in the sense of being
block questions and the decomposition
theorem says that if you have any two
high entropy distributions you come a V
you can write them as a convex
combination of aligned conjunctive block
Wasden sources with exponentially small
error okay so let me elaborate on the
parameters so here's here are U and V
which are high mean entropy so they're
missing T symbols of entropy right I can
write them as a convex combination of D
CBD sources which are aligned so each
one of them has roughly some constant
times T many fixed coordinates and
remaining you have block questions up to
some exponential error in the P the
number of coordinates that you fixing
this is the main decomposition theorem
and it turns out that once you have this
you can show what we really wanted which
is that if you start out with these
functions distributions you come a V
being very high mean entropy then they
out this acceptance function is a
non-negative sum of of T non-negative
hunters and this can we can plug in to
where we came from and complete the
analysis
so in the remaining couple of minutes
let me say a couple of words about how
to prove the decomposition theorem
I won't say much about the analysis but
the proof at least how we find the
decomposition is fairly greedy you do
the thing that is most natural in some
sense so what's our goal we have this
distributions X comma Y or random
variables X comma Y a sample from U
comma V which have very high mean
entropy okay and we'd like to decompose
them into this nice structured sources
well if they were already structured we
are done okay we can go home but if not
then there must be something which is
violating the constraint so for example
let's say X was not blocked questions
that means it has a little smaller
entropy than it should have
in some subset of coordinates let's call
it I so there is some subset of
coordinates I where it was giving too
much mass to one specific assignment
then it should have let's call it alpha
I so we have this kind of violation of a
block buzzer density condition and to
fix it what we do is just conditioned on
it
we split the source X comma Y into two
pieces one way be conditioned on this
event happening the even that's
violating the block wise density and the
one other one which is a negation of it
the hope is they break conditioning on
it we at least get block wise density in
the remaining well this is good but not
quite good because here X and we're no
longer aligned we fixed we fixed some
coordinates in X but not in Y how do you
fix that I'm going to be really sort of
greedy again and consider all possible
conditionings of Y in the things that
are fixed in X and just can look at all
possible conditions of Y I so I get 2 to
the B times I many branches and then I
iterate okay is our each of these pieces
block west ends yes maybe no I split
again and keep going
so that's the algorithm and in
termination you want to show that you
never you terminate the algorithm when
the piece gets too small meaning it's
very very unlikely compared to their
parent or you fix too many coordinates
which is a problem for us and then you
have to show that both of these events
do not lose too much mass the only lose
exponentially smaller case out then
again we have the decomposition theorem
which which which we can show that this
functions au we are simple from which we
can show a lower bound on the non
negative rank of pattern matrices from
which we get the CSP lower bounds let me
finish with some open problems I think
the main open problem going forward is
showing a similar result for a semi
definite rank for positive semi definite
rank here the best lower bound is n to
the Omega log n coming from the work of
Leonardo and Ernst Reuter
but it's from completely different
techniques so there's nothing which is
kind of bridging the two right now and
the second open problem which also came
up in mica stock was to prove a lifting
tier for non negative rank when the
alphabet size was constant okay so right
now we have a tight lifting theorem but
the alphabet size had to be some 10
times log n but if you show it for a
constant all of the cs biloba or many of
the CSP lower ones i mentioned in
serving sub-exponential for instance
will become exponential to be 7 or 8
plus epsilon you need to to the Omega n
size LPS it's kind of ETH for X and
reformulations
and finally there are many other
interesting gadgets for which we'd like
to prove lifting theorems for example
lifting theorems for permutations so
here think of drawers being bit strings
and the Collins being permutations and
the x5 entry is f of PI of X can we
characterize the non-negative rank of
this lifted matrix in terms of some
property of F
and in a very recent work lee myself and
vidiq and passing Drago indra and un
found a simpler analysis of the theorems
that I mentioned the lifting theorem for
non-negative rank but that's for the
indexing gadget it's kind of ask a
symmetric gadget but you can get the
same results for csps as we did using a
much simpler analysis so so first is is
the difference between what CLRS tip and
what you're doing is a cure using
miniature P that is a difference but I'd
say that's a minor one it's mine it's
probably it's probably a minor one so
and where did I kind of got lost as to
where the gadget fits into the lifting
fear right right so this decomposition
theorem is gadget oblivious right I mean
you're just showing something for
distributions then there's no gadgets
there a guy just show up is this example
three that a here G is a to source
extractor right so here I said like if
you J + VJ for example our high entropy
you want the output of the gadget to be
close to being uniform and this is true
only for certain kinds of gadgets
oh you mean from CLRS
yeah yeah yeah so answer your first
question James is pointing out that one
of the main differences is CRS is trying
to find Hunter approximations and if you
dig into what we are doing we're finding
approximations in a very different sort
of error metric
we can tell you about that more so but
regardless your decomposition theorem
has no gas did
there's no gadget in it right and in the
simpler analysis that I mentioned it's
for its for another gadget the indexing
gadget which is kind of the mother of
all gadgets if it's true for any gadget
is true for the indexing gadget and so
there the decomposition theorem becomes
much simpler but this extractor
statement that I mentioned becomes a
little trickier than what it is for
inner product sort of I mean that you
get so what happens is that if you have
gadget size V then error becomes active
to the minus Omega P so imagine that you
have to to the error minus Omega B in
each of the coordinates now you have n
coordinates I want something statistical
distance I need to kill off to the minus
B with M okay it's not strictly true but
that's one of the things and that's one
reason why this analysis breaks down
when you take B to be a small constant
other questions
or the nightstand the speaker again
[Applause]